- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
En votre nom à tous,
je tiens à adresser
les félicitations
de la représentation
nationale
à nos compatriotes
lauréats du prix Nobel
de physique 2023.
Applaudissements
Merci beaucoup.
L'ordre du jour
appelle les questions
au gouvernement.
La première d'entre
elles va être posée
par madame Hélène Laporte
pour le Rassemblement National.
- Hélène Laporte: Merci.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer.
Quels démentis
plus sanglants
pour un homme d'Etat
que ceux qui émanent
de ses propres services?
Malgré l'autosatisfaction
à laquelle
vous nous avez habitués,
le bilan statistique
en sécurité et délinquance
de jeudi dernier
nous offre le sombre tableau
de l'ensauvagement
de notre pays.
Loin d'admettre
votre échec, vous tentez
de noyer la vérité des chiffres.
Vous affirmiez
ce matin même
que la hausse spectaculaire
des infractions
en 2022 ne constituait
qu'un rattrapage
après deux années de Covid.
C'est faux.
Sur toute la période
2017-2022,
les homicides
ont augmenté de 16%,
les coups et blessures
volontaires
de 52%, les violences
sexuelles de 103%.
Le Covid
ne pourra pas éternellement
vous servir d'excuse.
On nous annonçait ce matin
une baisse importante
de la délinquance
depuis janvier 2023.
Nous ne sommes pas amnésiques.
En septembre dernier,
vous annonciez déjà attendre
une baisse des violences
intrafamiliales
sur l'année 2022.
Les chiffres montrent l'inverse.
Permettez-nous la prudence.
Nous discuterons
des chiffres de 2023
quand ils paraîtront.
En attendant, 2022
est un désastre.
Les étrangers représentent 18%
des auteurs d'homicides
et des auteurs de vols violents.
La très timide hausse
des OQTF en 2022
ne nous fera pas oublier
la chute
de 73% de ces OQTF
entre 2012 et 2021.
Par quel prodige
espérez-vous obtenir demain
des résultats différents
en poursuivant inlassablement
la même politique?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin:
Bonjour, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée,
je vous trouvais
moins agressive hier
avec le président
de la République,
lorsqu'il a annoncé 285 brigades
de gendarmerie,
alors qu'il était
dans votre région.
C'est vrai
que madame Le Pen
n'était pas là pour faire
la commissaire politique.
Vous avez dit au président
et à moi-même
à quel point
vous étiez heureuse
de voir ces annonces
en matière de sécurité
pour notre pays.
Il est vrai
qu'on fait parfois
de la politique
différemment à Paris
que dans sa propre
circonscription.
C'est vrai,
parce que dans le propre
programme de madame Le Pen,
elle prévoyait
7500 policiers supplémentaires.
Nous en faisons 8500.
Elle prévoyait 1 milliard
d'euros supplémentaires
pour le ministère de l'Intérieur.
Nous en prévoyons 15.
Vous faites beaucoup
de références
à la politique
et à des chiffres,
mais jamais aux policiers
et aux gendarmes
à qui vous ne rendez
jamais hommage.
Vous savez
que depuis les neuf premiers
mois de l'année,
y compris
dans votre département,
c'est entre -15
et -30 %.
Concernant les reconduites
à la frontière,
nous avons publié
les chiffres
il y a un mois.
Nous avons 14% de reconduite
à la frontière
en plus.
L'insécurité,
c'est ce qui fait monter
les voix du Front National.
Les moyens
pour la police,
c'est ce que font les partis
de gouvernement.
Je suis heureux
de pouvoir dire
que je remercie avant
tout les policiers
et les gendarmes qui font
un travail exemplaire.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Vous n'avez qu'une seconde.
- Hélène Laporte:
Je voudrais simplement dire
à monsieur le ministre...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Désolée, mais c'était
une seconde.
La parole est à monsieur
Rémy Rebeyrotte.
- Rémy Rebeyrotte:
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs
les membres
du gouvernement, chers collègues.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur.
Vous avez fait
le constat que suite
à des décisions
prises il y a 15 ans
ou parce que des besoins
nouveaux
ont émergé, le maillage
de notre territoire
en gendarmerie faisait
l'objet de mitage
et qu'il était temps
de le redensifier.
Cela correspond
à un engagement pris
par le chef de l'Etat
durant la campagne présidentielle.
238 nouvelles brigades fixes
ou mobiles seront créées.
Ces annonces vont au-delà
des engagements
du président
de la République,
qui avait promis
à l'époque 200 brigades.
Dans ma circonscription,
une brigade mobile viendra
répondre aux questions
spécifiques
des communes du massif du Morvan.
Il y aura
trois autres brigades
dans les environs
qui renforceront
les effectifs
et combleront les manques.
Mes collègues
de Saône-et-Loire
sont également
très actifs sur le sujet.
Ce nouveau plan est exemplaire.
Dans d'autres
domaines, je pense
aux structures hospitalières,
lorsqu'un mitage
a été créé,
il ne faut pas hésiter
à revenir
sur des décisions
qui ont été prises.
Quelles sont les prochaines
étapes
du plan et comment
se concrétiseront
ces nouvelles implantations?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
C'est grâce au travail
du Parlement,
lors du vote de la loi
de programmation
du ministère
de l'Intérieur,
et grâce aux crédits
accordés par madame
la Première ministre
et par le président
de la République
que nous pouvons moderniser
et renforcer
les effectifs de police
et de gendarmerie partout
sur le territoire national.
Peut-être pendant le premier
quinquennat
n'avons-nous pas assez
souligné
que les effectifs
de la DGSI ont doublé.
Nous avons ainsi
déjoué un attentat
tous les deux mois.
Nous avons augmenté
les renforts
dans les grands
centres urbains
comme Paris, Marseille,
Lyon ou Lille.
Ce deuxième quinquennat
sera peut-être
celui de zones
plus périurbaines,
avec la création
de ces brigades
de gendarmerie.
Jusqu'en 2017,
les gouvernements
ont supprimé 500
brigades en 20 ans.
Ils ont concentré
les effectifs de gendarmerie
dans les zones les plus urbaines.
Quand le président a promis
ces 200 brigades,
il s'adaptait aux difficultés
du service public.
Les élus ont pu
répondre en métropole
et en outre-mer.
Nous avons déjà recruté 600
des 2140 gendarmes
qui permettront
d'armer ces brigades
de gendarmerie nouvelle.
Chaque année,
nous allons former
de nouveaux
effectifs pour tenir
les 2144 gendarmes.
Les constructions,
elles, commenceront
dès la fin de l'année.
Les premières
inaugurations,
nous les espérons dès 2025.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Mathilde Panot.
- Mathilde Panot:
Madame la présidente,
madame la Première ministre.
Une vague de panique
saisit le pays.
Les punaises
de lit prolifèrent
dans tous les lieux du quotidien.
Hôpitaux, écoles,
prisons, foyers
de travailleurs ou même
salles de cinéma.
Elles font vivre un calvaire
à nos concitoyens infestés.
Les punaises de lit
sont un problème national
de santé publique.
Vous n'avez rien fait!
En 2017, il y avait 200.000
lieux infestés.
J'ai alerté,
vous n'avez rien fait.
En 2019,
il y avait plus de 500.000
sites infestés.
Nous avons déposé
une résolution
pour exiger
un plan d'urgence,
vous n'avez rien fait.
En 2020, il y avait 950.000
sites infestés.
Nous avons interpellé
le gouvernement,
vous n'avez rien fait.
Rien ou presque,
un numéro vert
et une plate-forme
fantôme
qui a depuis disparu.
En 2022, il y avait 1,1 million
de sites infestés.
Vous avez agi avec un plan
interministériel
sans aucune mesure
contraignante
et un observatoire
qui n'a jamais
vu le jour.
C'est votre inaction
qui est responsable aujourd'hui
de cette situation explosive.
Plus vous attendez,
plus cette situation devient
incontrôlable.
Quand allez-vous interdire
les produits chimiques
inefficaces?
Quand allez-vous
cesser de livrer
les citoyens à eux-mêmes
et à la voracité
des entreprises privées?
Nous exigeons
un service public
de la désinsectisation gratuit,
efficace, garant
de la santé et de l'environnement.
Ces petits insectes
répandent le désespoir
dans notre pays.
Faut-il attendre
que Matignon soit infecté
pour que vous réagissiez?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Elisabeth Borne.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs
les députés, madame
la présidente Mathilde Panot.
Il y a des sujets
qui ne devraient
pas prêter à la polémique
et aux divisions.
Un peu de décence!
Oui, les punaises de lit
sont une angoisse
pour nos concitoyens
qui craignent d'y
être confrontés.
C'est un véritable
calvaire
pour ceux qui sont touchés.
L'infestation
d'un logement peut devenir
un enfer
pour ceux qui y habitent
et les solutions
pour s'en débarrasser peuvent
être coûteuses.
Sur ce sujet,
il ne devrait pas
y avoir de clivage,
mais une détermination collective
pour agir.
Pourquoi, une fois
de plus, restez-vous
dans l'outrance?
Pourquoi
ne dites-vous pas
qu'il y a un an et demi,
en mars 2022,
le plan interministériel
de lutte
contre les punaises
de lit, porté
par le ministère
de la Transition écologique,
du Logement
et de la Santé,
a apporté des premières réponses?
Ce plan, c'est d'abord
de la sensibilisation
pour mieux repérer
les infestations
et informer les particuliers
et professionnels concernés.
C'est aussi
un accompagnement
de la filière de lutte
contre les nuisibles
pour offrir de meilleurs
traitements
et offrir
des professionnels formés
et reconnus.
L'observatoire
dont vous parliez
est en cours de création.
Les punaises de lit
ont infesté la plupart
des grandes villes du monde.
Les études nous montrent
que leur prolifération
est liée aux voyages touristiques.
Nous sommes pour autant
déterminés
à continuer à agir
et à amplifier
notre action.
Une réunion avec l'ensemble
des ministères concernés
se tiendra
dans les prochains jours.
La majorité
présidentielle a engagé
un travail pour trouver
des réponses
de long terme
sur l'accompagnement
des personnes touchées.
Cette réflexion devrait
rassembler largement
dans cet hémicycle.
Travaillons ensemble,
trouvons des solutions ensemble.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, madame
la Première ministre.
La parole est à madame
Annie Genevard.
- Annie Genevard: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre.
Depuis des mois,
nous sonnons l'alarme.
La construction et la vente
de logements s'effondrent.
Il y a 15 ans, on construisait
100.000 logements
de plus qu'aujourd'hui.
Le contingent des coûts
de construction,
le poids des normes,
la raréfaction
du foncier et la hausse des taux
d'intérêt empêchent l'acquisition
de logements par les ménages.
Le stock de logements
est très insuffisant.
Il est urgent d'en relancer
la construction
et d'en faciliter l'accès.
Vous faites exactement l'inverse.
Vous excluez du marché locatif
les logements classés G
dès 2025, puis F
puis E, soit 40%
du marché.
Il aurait fallu
différer cette mesure,
comme cela vous a été suggéré.
Depuis 2017, quelles mesures
avez-vous prises
pour encourager
la construction de logements?
Une fois
n'est pas coutume,
écoutez les Républicains.
Ne touchez pas au prêt a taux
zéro, défiscalisez
les intérêts pour permettre
aux Français d'emprunter
et d'accéder
à la propriété,
facilitez les dotations
pour permettre
aux jeunes générations
d'acquérir
plus vite leur résidence
principale.
Les Français
qui ne peuvent
plus se loger sont en colère.
Les entreprises
du bâtiment
sont aux abois.
Que comptez-vous
faire pour désamorcer
ce qui s'annonce
comme une bombe sociale?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu:
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs
les députés, madame
la députée Annie Genevard.
Ce matin même,
j'étais à l'ouverture
du 83e congrès
des logements sociaux.
Ce congrès a déjà conduit
à un certain nombre
de mesures,
comme le plafonnement
du taux du livret
A à 3%, la relance
du prêt à taux zéro
et d'autres mesures
sur lesquelles,
à ce stade,
je ne prolongerai pas
le propos,
parce qu'il y aura
d'autres questions
pendant cette séance.
Vous évoquez le sujet
des passoires énergétiques.
Je me réjouis
de rappeler les choses.
Il n'y a aucun texte en France
qui prévoit qu'à compter d'une
date, on va sortir
des locataires
d'un logement.
Il y a un texte
qui rappelle
qu'il y a une obligation
de travaux
et que si les travaux
ne sont pas faits
à cette date,
à la fin du bail,
quand il y a un changement
de locataire,
il faut
les faire avant d'accueillir
un nouveau locataire.
Je ne veux pas croire
que vous braquiez
les projecteurs
sur les propriétaires
qui ont du mal
à faire des travaux
sans regarder
les locataires
qui ont du mal à payer
leurs factures
en raison du fait
qu'ils habitent
dans une passoire énergétique.
Laisser penser
qu'on accélérera la sortie
du logement,
on trompe les Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Annie Genevard: Merci.
Parlons de MaPrimeRénov'.
Elle est censée favoriser
la rénovation énergétique
des logements.
C'est un bazar innommable.
Nous sommes sans arrêt
alertés
sur les dysfonctionnements
de MaPrimeRénov'...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci,
mais vous n'avez plus de temps.
La parole est à madame
Véronique Riotton.
- Véronique Riotton: Merci.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de la Santé
et de la Prévention.
Plus de 2 millions de femmes
sont atteintes d'endométriose
en France aujourd'hui.
2 millions de femmes
dont le diagnostic
est souvent tardif.
L'enjeu est de mieux
diagnostiquer, mieux accompagner
et soulager
celles qui souffrent
au quotidien de cette maladie.
Comme vous le savez
toutes et tous,
un texte opportuniste arrive
dans cet hémicycle.
On aurait préféré voir
leur auteur voter
la loi visant à améliorer
les conditions d'IVG,
la loi visant à reconnaître
l'endométriose
comme une affection
à longue durée.
En bref, il faut
s'intéresser vraiment
à la santé des femmes.
Nous travaillons
pour la santé des femmes
avec conviction
et détermination
depuis 2017.
Nous nous associons
avec les actions
des différents
comités féminins
pour le dépistage
du cancer du sein.
Il y a des actions formidables
qui accompagnent
les femmes au quotidien.
Mais les femmes
malades ne souhaitent
en rien être traitées
systématiquement
de victimes ou de personnes
en situation
de handicap.
Elles souhaitent
que le diagnostic
soit facilité,
que le parcours de soins
soit adapté, que les acteurs
des soins soient formés
et que la maladie
soit mieux connue.
Pouvez-vous nous faire
un point d'étape
sur la façon
dont vous comptez répondre
aux besoins qu'expriment
les femmes atteintes
d'endométriose et nous dresser
un premier bilan
des actions mises
en oeuvre au sein
de la stratégie
nationale de lutte
contre l'endométriose?
Merci beaucoup.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Aurélien Rousseau.
- Aurélien Rousseau:
Madame la présidente,
madame Véronique
Riotton, mesdames
et messieurs les députés,
l'endométriose
est un problème de santé publique.
1 femme sur 10
en est atteinte aujourd'hui.
Cela nécessite
une réponse collective
qui a commencé
il y a de nombreuses années,
sous l'impulsion notamment
des associations
de parlementaires
dans cette Assemblée.
Véronique Louwagie
ou Clémentine Autain,
par exemple, sous l'engagement
du gouvernement
et de cette majorité,
ont porté
une stratégie nationale
sur l'endométriose.
Ce sont des actes,
pas une récupération
de la 25e heure.
Demain matin,
avec Sylvie Retailleau
et Bérangère Couillard,
nous présiderons
à Rennes le comité
de pilotage
de cette stratégie
sur trois grands axes.
D'abord, toujours
mieux faire connaître
cette maladie.
Aujourd'hui encore,
certains considèrent
que c'est une maladie
de bonne femme.
Non, l'endométriose
est un sujet
de santé publique.
Nous voulons aussi
faire progresser
la recherche.
Troisièmement, toujours
et encore former
les professionnels,
faire connaître
cette maladie
pour mettre un terme
à l'errance du diagnostic.
Nous voulons aller
encore plus loin.
J'ai signé la semaine
dernière une instruction
pour reformer notamment
l'homogénéité
de la prise en charge
dans les affections
de longue durée.
Elle existe,
elle a augmenté de 50%
en un an et je pense
que c'est un sujet
de mobilisation
collective, plutôt
que d'appropriation
de dernière minute.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Christine Pires Beaune.
- Christine Pires Beaune: Merci.
Madame la ministre
des Solidarités
et de la Famille,
j'ai remis à madame
la Première ministre
et à vous-même
un rapport
sur le reste à charge
en EHPAD,
ainsi que plusieurs solutions
pour faire baisser celui-ci.
C'est une évolution globale
de l'action publique
dans le domaine
de la prise en charge
des personnes âgées
en termes d'autonomie
qui doit être mise
en oeuvre
et nous sommes beaucoup
à espérer
la loi grand âge
promise aux Français
depuis plus de 20 ans.
Depuis de longs
mois, les EHPAD
et les résidences tirent
la sonnette d'alarme.
Des facteurs conjecturaux
sont venus s'ajouter
aux autres facteurs dus
à un modèle obsolète.
Vous avez annoncé une enveloppe
de 100 millions d'euros
pour les établissements
et les services
à domicile.
C'est une bonne
chose, mais je peux
vous assurer que ce sera
insuffisant.
Comptez-vous aller plus loin
si la consolidation
des situations
confirme mes craintes?
Je reçois de nombreux
courriers
de toute la France.
Un monsieur hébergé
à Sartrouville
dans les Yvelines,
dans un EHPAD public,
a vu sa facture
augmenter de 205 euros
chaque mois.
Un habitant du Puy-de-Dôme a vu
sa facture augmenter
de 145 euros.
Ce ne sont pas des cas isolés.
76% des résidents
ne sont pas en mesure
de payer leur reste
à charge
avec leurs revenus mensuels.
Combien seront-ils
à la fin de l'année?
Comment allez-vous aider
420.000 résidents
et leur famille, confrontés
à des dépenses insoutenables?
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Aurore Bergé.
- Aurore Bergé: Merci.
Madame la députée,
merci pour le rapport
que vous nous avez remis,
ainsi que pour l'engagement
sincère qui est le vôtre
sur ce sujet.
Oui,
nous avons immédiatement
agi avec la Première
ministre
avec un fonds de 100
millions d'euros.
Ce n'est
normalement pas une compétence
immédiate de l'Etat,
mais nous venons
en aide aux services
à domicile
ainsi qu'aux EHPAD publics.
Nous allons réunir
les financeurs
et les créanciers.
Nous voulons
que les parlementaires soient
tenus informés
de la composition
et de la mise en oeuvre
des commissions départementales
qui ont été installées.
Voilà pour la réponse
de l'urgence.
Il y a ensuite des sujets
plus structurels,
sur le modèle économique
de nos EHPAD.
Il faut avoir un parcours
résidentiel
au bénéfice
des personnes âgées,
qu'elles puissent
rester vieillir
à leur domicile,
avoir un vrai parcours d'autonomie
dans des résidences
adaptées et enfin
avoir des EHPAD
de plus en plus médicalisés.
C'est une stratégie
que nous avons initiée
avec le ministre
de la Santé
et avec le ministre
de l'Enseignement supérieur
et de la Recherche.
Nous allons reprendre
le 20 novembre
une loi qui était attendue
par les parlementaires
et je crois
que vous aurez
dans cette loi
un certain nombre
de réponses.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
Madame Christine Pires Beaune?
- Christine Pires Beaune:
Nous devons avancer
le PLFSS pour mettre
fin à une iniquité
qui fait que le crédit
d'impôt ne concerne
que quelques-uns.
Il faut que tout le monde
soit concerné afin
de faire baisser
le reste à charge.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame la ministre?
- Aurore Bergé:
Nous avançons bien.
Nous allons
permettre la fusion
des sections soins et dépendances.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Davy Rimane.
- Davy Rimane: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre
des Transports.
Gustave Flaubert
disait que voyager
en des lieux modestes rend modeste
et permet de mieux voir
la place que l'on occupe
dans le monde.
En Guyane,
des dizaines de milliers
de personnes sont cloisonnées
à domicile, empêchées
de tout déplacement.
Elles n'ont jamais été
aussi conscientes
de la minuscule place
qu'elles occupent
dans ce pays réputé indivisible.
Les gens sont obligés
de prendre
la pirogue ou l'avion
dans un pays étranger.
La liquidation
d'Air Guyane annoncée
est le symbole
du désengagement de l'Etat.
Quand la population
guyanaise pourra-t-elle
se déplacer à nouveau librement?
Suivrez-vous
les recommandations
du rapport sénatorial
du 30 mars 2023
qui préconise de porter
la participation
de l'Etat à minimum
50% sur les lignes
les plus chères?
Il y a un kilomètre par an
de routes construites
sur un territoire de 90.000
kilomètres carrés.
Il faut un plan pluriannuel
de désenclavement
de la Guyane d'urgence.
La Guyane attend
des investissements publics
pour exercer la liberté
fondamentale d'aller
et venir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Clément Beaune.
- Clément Beaune: Merci.
Vous appelez
mon attention
et celle du gouvernement.
Je suis ce dossier sur le cas
extrêmement préoccupant
de la liquidation
de cette compagnie
de transport.
Cette liquidation
n'est pas l'échec d'une politique
de l'Etat.
Nous serons au rendez-vous
sur la continuité
en termes d'infrastructures.
La décision
qui a été prise
et que je regrette,
c'est la succession d'erreurs
de gestion d'une compagnie
qui desservent massivement
la Guyane et les Antilles.
Nous avons pu
échanger le jour même
de cette décision à votre demande.
Elle a des conséquences
sérieuses
en termes d'emploi.
Ce sont 76 emplois
mis en danger
en Guyane
et c'est encore plus dangereux
en termes de connexions
au sein du territoire.
Nous allons prendre
toutes les mesures nécessaires
pour assurer jour après jour
cette continuité.
Demain, un avion sera
présent en Guyane
pour assurer les liaisons
et connexions
les plus urgentes,
comme les évacuations sanitaires
ou l'approvisionnement
en médicaments.
Dans les trois semaines
qui viennent,
nous allons mettre
en place une délégation
de service public
d'urgence qui relèvera
de la collectivité
territoriale de Guyane.
Nous l'accompagnerons
afin qu'il n'y ait
aucune rupture.
Nous préparons aussi
une délégation
de service public
plus structurée
et pérenne.
L'Etat a toujours
été au rendez-vous
pour accompagner
cette délégation,
même si elle relève
en premier lieu
de la collectivité.
Je suis à votre disposition
pour continuer
ces échanges.
Nous ne laisserons pas tomber
la Guyane
ni aucune connexion
essentielle
dans les années qui viennent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur Davy Rimane?
- Davy Rimane:
Merci pour votre réponse,
mais vous ne m'avez pas répondu
quant
au plan pluriannuel
de désenclavement
de la Guyane.
En Guyane, il n'y
a que 500 kilomètres
de routes nationales.
Rien d'autre.
Il faut que les gens
puissent se déplacer
sur le territoire guyanais.
Il faut ouvrir
les discussions quant
à un plan pluriannuel.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Jean-Louis Bourlanges.
- Jean-Louis Bourlanges:
Madame la présidente,
madame la Première ministre,
mes chers collègues,
le nettoyage ethnique
du Haut-Karabakh
et ses dizaines
de milliers de victimes
ne sont que le premier acte.
Il faut agir.
Je vous pose
trois questions pour agir.
Le gouvernement
est-il prêt à saisir
le Conseil de sécurité
sur les décisions propres
à assurer la protection
des minorités arméniennes
demeurées au Haut-Karabakh
ainsi qu'à protéger,
à garantir l'intégrité
territoriale
et la souveraineté
de la République
de l'Arménie?
La question
des sanctions doit
être légitimement posée.
Deuxième question:
au-delà de l'aide humanitaire
d'urgence,
le gouvernement
n'estime-t-il pas nécessaire
de mettre
en place au niveau
de l'Union Européenne
un véritable plan Marshall
de réinstallation
des réfugiés afin
d'offrir un avenir
à ceux qui ont tout perdu
et de faire baisser
en Arménie même une tension
susceptible d'emporter
la démocratie?
Troisième question:
que comptez-vous faire
pour aider
militairement l'Arménie
à se défendre?
Entendez-vous
répondre rapidement
à sa demande d'armes?
L'Union Européenne
a jusqu'à présent refusé
à l'Arménie
la facilité européenne
pour la paix.
Ce refus peut-il enfin être levé?
L'honneur de l'Europe
est engagé
dans cette tragédie.
Si nous oublions
l'Arménie, nous oublions
ce que nous sommes et ce que
nous devons rester.
Assez d'indifférence!
Assez de complaisance!
L'Arménie doit vivre!
Applaudissements
...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup,
monsieur le président.
La parole est à madame
la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne:
Monsieur le président
Jean-Louis Bourlanges,
avant toute chose,
mes pensées
vont aux Arméniennes
et aux Arméniens.
Au moment
où je vous parle,
plus de 100.000 d'entre
eux ont dû fuir
du Haut-Karabakh,
fuir leurs terres
et leurs foyers.
C'est la quasi-totalité
des habitants
de cette région.
C'est un véritable exode
massif et organisé.
Monsieur le président
Bourlanges,
comme vous le soulignez,
cette situation
est d'une extrême gravité.
Après neuf mois
d'un blocus illégal,
nous faisons face
à une offensive militaire
de l'Azerbaïdjan en violation
du cessez-le-feu,
sous le regard
complice de la Russie,
qui a rompu tous ses engagements.
Je le dis devant vous,
nous condamnons fermement
ces actions de l'Azerbaïdjan.
Très vite, la France a pris
ses responsabilités.
Aujourd'hui même,
la ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères,
Catherine Colonna,
est en Arménie pour voir
comment renforcer
notre coopération
dans tous les domaines
et dire notre solidarité
au peuple arménien.
Nous sommes mobilisés
au plan humanitaire.
Notre aide a triplé pour atteindre
12,5 millions d'euros
depuis le début de l'année.
Une aide médicale
d'urgence est arrivée
en Arménie ces derniers jours.
A ce soutien
s'ajoutent les efforts
des collectivités
territoriales
et de la société civile,
que je veux saluer.
En parallèle à cette réponse
à l'urgence humanitaire,
la France est engagée
pour réaffirmer
son soutien sans faille
à la souveraineté
et à l'intégrité
territoriale de l'Arménie.
Nous agissons au sein
de l'Union Européenne.
L'Union intervient
au plan humanitaire
et a activé le mécanisme
de protection civile européen.
Nous sommes engagés
pour tirer
toutes les conséquences
de cette offensive militaire
et pour bâtir un véritable plan
européen d'appui
à une Arménie
indépendante, souveraine
et démocratique.
Nous continuons
également à mobiliser
le Conseil de sécurité
des Nations Unies
et à appeler l'ensemble
de ses membres
à prendre leurs responsabilités.
Une mission de l'ONU
est actuellement
au Haut-Karabakh pour évaluer
les besoins humanitaires.
Monsieur le président
Bourlanges,
la situation est grave.
Nous condamnons l'offensive
de l'Azerbaïdjan.
Nous sommes solidaires
du peuple arménien
et nous soutenons
la souveraineté
de l'Arménie.
La position de la France
est claire,
et nous continuerons
à la défendre:
aucune paix durable
ne pourra être atteinte
dans le Sud Caucase
par la menace
ou par la force.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Roger Chudeau.
- Roger Chudeau: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre
de l'Education nationale,
vous pouvez vous targuer
d'avoir réussi
une rentrée politique fracassante.
On vous a vu sur tous
les fronts: l'abaya,
le harcèlement...
Bravo, il était temps
de mettre fin
à ces scandales
au bout de six ans.
Cela dit,
votre rentrée scolaire
est moins brillante,
car il ne se passe
pas un jour
sans qu'il ne manque
des professeurs dans 50%
de nos établissements,
et le système
de remplacement
ne marche pas
et ne peut pas marcher,
vous le savez.
Mais parlons maintenant
de l'essentiel,
c'est-à-dire du projet
de politique éducative
que vous devriez présenter
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Quand on vous parle
de ce projet,
vous répondez
que l'école républicaine
est son propre projet.
C'est une belle
pirouette,
mais que reste-t-il
de la promesse républicaine
de l'élévation du niveau
de connaissance,
quand 11% de nos adolescents
sont illettrés,
que la moitié
des élèves de 6e
ne savent pas lire
en entrant en sixième
et que le baccalauréat
ne vaut
plus rien?
Que reste-t-il de la promesse
d'assimilation républicaine
lorsque les collégiens
mettent le feu
à leur collège?
Que reste-t-il de la promesse
d'élévation...
D'ascenseur
social de l'école
de la République par le mérite?
Il ne reste rien.
Vous n'avez
même pas prononcé
en deux mois le mot de REP,
réseau d'éducation prioritaire.
Vous parlez ensuite
de choc des savoirs
en parlant d'une nouvelle sixième.
Parlons-en:
une demi-heure de français
et une demi-heure
de maths en plus.
Ce serait risible.
Ca n'est pas sérieux.
Il n'y a pas de choc
des savoirs,
il n'y a pas de politique
éducative
à l'heure actuelle.
Nous avions un ministre
quasi mutique.
Maintenant,
nous avons un hyper loquace.
C'est très bien,
sauf que vous ne faites
que poser des pansements
sur le grand corps malade qu'est
l'Education nationale.
Vous n'avez pas de pensée
stratégique.
Quand présenterez-vous
un projet pédagogique
de l'école?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Gabriel Attal.
- Gabriel Attal:
Monsieur le député Roger Chudeau,
vous avez commencé
votre question
en faisant référence
à la rentrée scolaire.
En démarrant ma réponse,
je veux rendre hommage
à tous les enseignants,
chefs d'établissement,
personnels
de l'Education nationale
qui se sont mobilisés
en cette rentrée
pour nos élèves.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
S'il vous plaît,
un peu de silence.
- Gabriel Attal:
Vous avez ensuite qualifié
l'Education nationale
de grand corps malade.
Je rappelle
que vous avez été membre
de l'inspection
générale, directeur
de l'encadrement
du ministère et conseiller
de François Fillon
pour l'éducation
pendant cinq ans.
Si le ministère
de l'Education nationale
est un grand corps
malade, il me semble
que vous avez aussi une part
de responsabilité
dans la situation
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui.
Oui,
l'étiquette RN
ne suffit pas à se faire
passer
pour un antisystème!
Enfin,
mon ambition est bel
et bien d'élever
le niveau de nos élèves.
A ce titre,
nous avons un grand motif
de fierté depuis 2017:
le dédoublement
des classes en REP
et REP+ qui permet
à 500.000 élèves
aujourd'hui de faire
une rentrée dans une classe à 12.
Nous constatons
déjà que les écarts
en français
et en mathématiques
se sont drastiquement
réduits
depuis que nous avons mis
en place
cette politique.
Evidemment qu'il faut poursuivre.
C'est la raison
pour laquelle je serai amené
à annoncer des mesures
supplémentaires s'agissant
du niveau de l'élévation
du niveau
en français et en mathématiques.
Il faut enfin
reconquérir le mois
de juin pour le baccalauréat.
Le nouveau calendrier
nous permettra
de garder les élèves
au collège
et au lycée jusqu'à
la fin du mois
de juin.
C'est déjà une partie
de l'élévation
du niveau.
Il faudra apporter des initiatives
supplémentaires.
Je ferai des annonces
ce jeudi
en la matière.
J'avancerai sur cet
enjeu dans les mois
qui viennent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur le député?
- Roger Chudeau:
Vous mettez en cause
un fonctionnaire sur l'état
de déliquescence
du système éducatif.
Vous vous trompez.
Ceux qui sont responsables
du désastre,
ce sont...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à Sandrine Rousseau.
- Sandrine Rousseau: Merci.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer.
Laissez-moi vous proposer
un exercice
de fiction.
Imaginez la ville de Strasbourg,
270.000 habitants
à peu près, privée
d'eau deux jours
sur trois.
Imaginez que, lorsque
l'eau coule enfin
du robinet,
elle soit marron,
qu'elle donne la diarrhée.
Imaginez que des enfants
n'aillent
plus à l'école faute d'eau.
Imaginez-vous
dans l'impossibilité
de vous laver
deux jours sur trois.
Et pour boire,
les habitants
de cette ville doivent
acheter des packs d'eau
entre 6 et 10 euros
qui font l'objet
de spéculations
et peuvent se revendre
encore plus cher.
Tout cela se passe
à Mayotte,
et c'est loin, Mayotte, très loin.
Pourtant, Mayotte,
c'est la France.
Bien sûr, on peut dire
qu'il s'agit d'une sécheresse
exceptionnelle,
mais ce ne serait voir qu'une
seule partie du problème.
Ce dont il s'agit ici,
c'est bien d'une crise
de l'abandon par l'Etat:
faute d'entretien,
40% de fuites,
pas de traitement
des déchets ni de lutte
contre la pollution,
aucune démarche
d'association pour trouver
une solution,
pas d'anticipation
par les recherches.
La situation n'est pas nouvelle.
29% des résidences
à Mayotte
n'ont pas accès
à l'eau potable,
contre moins de 1%
dans l'Hexagone.
Sans eau, tout est menacé.
Bien sûr, le ministre
des Outre-mer
a proposé 35 millions
d'investissements d'urgence,
1/10 du coût
de l'autoroute A69,
quelques bouteilles d'eau,
350 millions investis
on ne sait pas quand,
des pansements,
du déni.
On ne l'accepterait pas
une seconde
dans l'Hexagone.
Pourquoi l'accepter à Mayotte?
Ma question est simple:
pour le gouvernement,
les Mahorais sont-ils
des Français
comme les autres?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin:
Madame la députée
Sandrine Rousseau,
imaginez une députée
qui pose une question
sur Mayotte
sans jamais s'y être rendue.
Madame la députée...
Votre intervention
est particulièrement démagogique.
Vous comparez les 50.000
bouteilles d'eau
que distribue
l'armée française
en ce moment même
à Mayotte, vous comparez
les difficultés
de nos compatriotes Mahorais
pour lesquels
le gouvernement fait
des efforts
parce qu'il n'y
a pas de nappe
phréatique à Mayotte
pour servir
vos intérêts politiques
sans vous être rendue
auprès des Mahorais.
Travaillez plutôt
avec une pour fournir
à la population mahoraise
sa véritable autonomie
en eau.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame Rousseau?
- Sandrine Rousseau:
Imaginez un ministre
qui parle de sécheresse
sans jamais
avoir compris
le réchauffement climatique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur le ministre?
- Gérald Darmanin:
Madame la députée,
vous ne voulez pas voir
que l'un
des problèmes à Mayotte,
c'est sa surpopulation,
et que lorsque
nous nous battons
pour des opérations
de reconduite
à la frontière,
lorsque nous nous battons
pour la scolarisation
des enfants, lorsque
nous nous battons
pour construire
un deuxième centre
hospitalier,
vous votez
contre toutes les décisions
qui concernent Mayotte!
Et aujourd'hui,
vous voulez nous faire croire,
alors que les Mahorais
réclament
la fermeté
de la République,
que vous êtes de leur côté?
Mais venez donc
un jour,
dans trois mois,
quand nous irons
à Mayotte, nous accompagner!
Sortez de Paris!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Didier Le Gac.
- Didier Le Gac: Merci.
Mes chers collègues,
ma question s'adresse
à monsieur Hervé Berville,
secrétaire d'Etat
à la mer.
J'associe avec moi
de nombreux collègues
de tous les littoraux français.
La pêche est en crise.
Ce n'est pas la première
fois, certes,
mais cette fois,
cette crise liée
à la hausse du carburant
et à l'inflation menace
toute la filière.
En Bretagne notamment,
région qui représente
la moitié de la pêche
débarquée en France,
tout le monde est mobilisé.
Vous avez reçu
un courrier de l'ensemble
des acteurs économiques
et politiques faisant part
de leur très grande inquiétude.
Un marin-pêcheur
de ma circonscription
me disait encore ce matin:
"Si les bateaux s'arrêtent,
cette fois,
c'est toute la filière
qui risque de s'arrêter."
Je sais
que vous êtes mobilisé,
et vous avez annoncé des mesures.
D'abord, un plan
de verdissement
du carburant maritime
avec une ristourne
de 13 centimes
par litre de gasoil.
Ensuite, une meilleure
répartition
de la taxe
sur les éoliennes en mer
en faveur de la pêche.
Ces annonces sont bienvenues.
Cependant,
il faut reconnaître
qu'elles ne prendront effet qu'à
moyen-long terme.
Or, ce qui est en jeu,
c'est bien
la survie de notre pêche.
La pêche française
est l'une
des plus respectueuses des normes
environnementales
et sociales, l'une
des plus contrôlées aussi.
Ce qui est en jeu
aussi,
c'est bien la question
de notre souveraineté alimentaire.
Je rappelle
qu'on importe déjà
les deux tiers
des produits de la mer
que nous consommons.
Oui, notre flotte
doit se moderniser,
et oui, notre filière doit
mieux s'organiser.
Mais dans l'immédiat,
ce que nous vous demandons,
c'est que la France
pèse
de toutes ses forces auprès
de l'Union Européenne afin
de prolonger
après le 15 octobre
le dispositif Ukraine
ainsi que le relèvement
des plafonds a minima,
indispensables
pour pouvoir investir.
Pouvez-vous nous faire
un point détaillé
sur les actions
que mène et mènera
le gouvernement
pour soutenir sa pêche?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Hervé Berville.
- Hervé Berville:
Monsieur le député
Le Gac,
le gouvernement a été,
est et restera auprès
de nos pêcheurs partout
sur nos littoraux,
parce que nous croyons
en l'avenir
de la filière
et de cette profession.
Vous le savez, face
à cette situation
et face au fait
que toutes les grandes crises
de la pêche
sont des crises
qui sont liées à la hausse
du carburant, l'Etat
a été présent.
75 millions d'euros
ont été mobilisés
depuis plus d'un an
pour faire en sorte
que les bateaux
continuent de sortir
et mettre en oeuvre
cette aide au carburant.
Mais vous le savez aussi,
le cadre européen actuel,
à ce stade,
ne nous permet pas de prolonger
l'aide au carburant
au-delà du 15 octobre.
Face
à cette urgence,
nous avons fait trois choses.
Premièrement,
nous avons accéléré
la mise en oeuvre
de mécanismes de solidarité
au sein de la filière
et avec les acteurs privés,
et c'est notamment la mise
en oeuvre d'une ristourne
de 13 centimes par Total
et par d'autres énergéticiens.
Surtout,
nous poursuivons le combat
que nous avons mené
pour prolonger l'aide
au carburant au niveau européen.
Nous allons le faire
dans les prochains jours
et les prochains
mois pour faire
en sorte de ne laisser
personne
dans l'impasse
et d'avoir cette prolongation
de l'aide au carburant.
Et puis, nous allons
mettre, territoire
par territoire,
des mécanismes
avec les banques,
avec la direction générale
des finances publiques,
pour accompagner
des entreprises de pêche,
pour que personne
ne se trouve dans une situation
impossible, notamment
avec un manque de trésorerie.
Vous voyez l'ambition
qui est la nôtre,
c'est de renforcer
la souveraineté économique
de notre pays,
et à long terme aussi,
c'est de réduire
notre dépendance
au carburant,
avec ce plan de réduction
de la dépendance
aux énergies fossiles
que j'ai annoncé,
qui permettra la transition
énergétique des navires.
450 millions d'euros issus
de la taxe éolienne
sont là
pour avoir des navires
moins gourmands en carburant.
C'est ce que nous allons
porter ensemble.
Merci
pour la mobilisation
de tous les députés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Ersilia Soudais.
- Ersilia Soudais:
Madame la présidente,
monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur,
comme vous ne pouvez
l'ignorer, monsieur
le maire de Grabels, René Revol,
a été victime d'une agression
dans une rue de Montpellier.
Des militants d'extrême
droite l'ont plaqué
au mur avant de lui dire:
"Tu ne perds rien
pour attendre, l'ami des Arabes."
Nous lui renouvelons
notre solidarité pleine
et entière au nom
de mon groupe parlementaire,
mais également,
je l'espère, au nom
de l'Assemblée nationale.
Applaudissements
Ces événements font suite
à plusieurs tentatives
d'intimidation à son encontre.
Tout l'été, René Revol
n'a pas cessé
de recevoir
un raz-de-marée d'injures
et de menaces de mort,
suite à sa prise
de position
contre la décision du maire
de Béziers qui refusait,
au mépris
de la loi, de marier
une Française
et un Algérien.
La violence
de l'extrême droite
n'est pas nouvelle.
Je me souviens
de mon père à l'hôpital.
Je me souviens des mini
pierres tombales
dans la boîte
aux lettres familiale.
Mais l'agression
de René Revol s'inscrit
dans un contexte
national inquiétant.
La peste brune
se répand, multipliant
les menaces, agressions,
ratonnades, incendies
et tentatives
d'assassinats,
dans le silence complice
de votre gouvernement.
Il fut un temps
où des femmes
et des hommes engagés
sous des bannières différentes
se sont retrouvés
autour d'un combat commun
contre le fascisme.
Gloire à eux et honte
à vous, monsieur
le ministre!
Combien de drames
vous faudra-t-il
pour comprendre la dangerosité
de l'extrême droite?
A quand une réaction immédiate
des autorités lorsque celles-ci
menacent puis passent à l'action?
Le danger,
ce n'est pas la gauche sociale
et écologique que nous incarnons.
Le danger, c'est l'extrême droite.
C'est sa conception
de la République biaisée
et son manque
d'humanité
ainsi que ses projets d'attentats.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Dominique Faure.
- Dominique Faure:
Madame la députée...
Cris de protestation
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
S'il vous plaît,
seule madame la ministre
a la parole.
Asseyez-vous!
- Dominique Faure:
Madame la députée Ersilia
Soudais...
-
Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Si vous ne vous
asseyez pas,
je vous rappelle à l'ordre.
Madame la députée,
vous êtes rappelée
à l'ordre.
Je viens de prononcer
à votre encontre
un rappel à l'ordre.
Si vous continuez,
ce sera la sanction supérieure.
Madame la ministre,
vous avez la parole.
- Dominique Faure:
Au nom de la Première ministre
et au nom
du gouvernement,
je tiens à condamner
cette agression
avec la plus grande
fermeté,
et nous apportons à monsieur
le maire René Revol
tout notre soutien
et toute notre solidarité.
Je veux souligner ici
le travail exemplaire
des services de l'Etat
et les en remercier.
René Revol a été agressé
le samedi 23 septembre
à Montpellier, en marge
de la manifestation
contre les violences policières.
Dès le dimanche
24 septembre,
il était contacté
par les services
de police pour l'inviter
à porter plainte.
Le lundi 25 septembre,
ce sont les forces
de gendarmerie
sur sa commune
qui se sont déplacées
pour l'entendre
et pour lui permettre
de déposer
sa plainte dans sa mairie.
Oui, les services
de l'Etat, les forces
de sécurité intérieure,
les préfets, oui,
sont présents auprès
des élus locaux.
Oui, nous allons vers eux,
élus, parlementaires,
gouvernements et services
de l'Etat devront marcher main
dans la main.
Je sais que dans cet
hémicycle,
nous sommes tous
solidaires
de tous les élus
victimes de violences.
Le 17 mai, j'énonçais
le pacte de sécurité
et en juillet,
le plan de lutte
contre les violences
faites aux élus.
Le Sénat va étudier
la semaine prochaine
une proposition
de loi visant
à encore mieux
protéger les élus,
et qui comprend notamment
un durcissement
des sanctions
pénales à l'encontre
des personnes
se rendant coupables
de violences envers les élus.
Le gouvernement salue
cette initiative.
Plusieurs députés parmi lesquels
Sébastien Jumel travaille aussi
sur ce sujet.
Je suis certaine
que tous ces travaux s'enrichiront
les uns avec les autres.
Sur ces sujets,
plutôt que l'invective,
plutôt
que l'agressivité,
c'est dans l'écoute,
le respect mutuel
et la solidarité que nous devons
ensemble apporter
une réponse...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, madame
la ministre.
Madame la députée?
- Ersilia Soudais:
Alors ainsi,
c'est nous, les violents?
Si vous n'agissez pas,
la bête immonde
que vous nourrissez
va vous mordre
la main à vous aussi.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à Serge Muller.
- Serge Muller: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
à monsieur Bruno
Le Maire.
Alors qu'aujourd'hui,
le taux de pauvreté
chez les agriculteurs
ne fait qu'augmenter,
au même rythme que le taux
de suicides, voilà
que vous venez leur retirer
un avantage d'une importance
capitale pour le monde
agricole:
la niche fiscale
du gazole non routier.
C'est, selon vous,
une fiscalité
qui incite à consommer
des énergies fossiles.
Vous voulez donc
les inciter à passer
à l'énergie verte,
comme si un agriculteur
de Dordogne,
qui a 500 euros pour vivre
à la fin du mois,
avait les moyens
de faire ces investissements.
Vous nous expliquez
également
que cela participerait
à une économie
de 10 milliards
d'euros, mais au prix
de combien de fermes
et de combien
de vies, quand 200
exploitations mettent
la clé sous la porte
chaque semaine
et que deux agriculteurs
se suicident
par jour?
Ces 10 milliards d'euros,
c'est la somme
que le président
avait promis d'investir
dans la transition
écologique,
et vous avez été les chercher
en grande partie
dans la poche
de la profession
la plus pauvre de France.
Quelle honte!
Si vous voulez faire
des économies,
la recette est là.
Taxez
les superprofits,
comme nous ne cessons
de vous le demander.
Cessez de soigner
gratuitement
avec l'argent
des Français
ceux qui sont illégalement
sur notre territoire.
Investissez
l'argent récupéré
dans la survie
de nos agriculteurs,
c'est la moindre des choses.
Parce que là
est ma question:
où sont les mesures
compensatoires
pour la survie
de leur activité,
quand vous les amputez
d'un avantage économique
indispensable?
Nous n'avons rien vu
et nous n'avons rien entendu.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire:
Monsieur le député Serge Muller,
où êtes-vous allé pêcher ces 10
milliards d'euros?
Brouhaha
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur Muller?
Vous pouvez
reprendre la parole,
si vous le souhaitez.
- Serge Muller:
Je pense que vous n'avez
aucune empathie
pour nos agriculteurs.
Gabriel Attal préconise
des cours d'empathie.
Inscrivez-vous d'urgence.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
Monsieur le ministre?
- Bruno Le Maire:
Monsieur le député Muller,
vous n'étiez pas encore élu
député
que j'étais ministre
de l'Agriculture.
J'ai été trois ans
le défenseur
des paysans
et des agriculteurs,
et je n'ai eu
de cesse de me battre
pour eux.
La différence
entre vous et nous,
c'est que nous,
nous voulons accompagner
les agriculteurs
dans la transition écologique,
et que nous le faisons
avec leur accord.
La réduction
de l'avantage fiscal
sur le GNR a été
décidée
non pas
contre les agriculteurs
mais avec eux,
avec la FNSEA,
avec les syndicats
agricoles,
dans le dialogue
et dans la concertation.
Nous le faisons progressivement.
Je ne sais pas où vous êtes allé
pêcher
ces 10 milliards d'euros.
2,8 centimes par litre
de carburant, voilà
ce que nous allons
faire, année
après année.
Nous ne leur retirons pas
d'avantage fiscal.
Nous leur laissons 35 centimes
d'avantage fiscal
par litre
de carburant à la fin
de la trajectoire.
L'engagement
que je prends, moi
qui pense aux agriculteurs,
qui soutiens
les agriculteurs
et qui les aide
dans leur transition
écologique,
c'est que l'intégralité
des recettes fiscales,
qui résulteront
de cette évolution
de la fiscalité
sur le GNR,
toute la recette ira
vers les agriculteurs,
pour les agriculteurs,
pour les accompagner
dans leur transition
écologique
et leur permettre de réussir
leur transition.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à François Jolivet.
- François Jolivet: Merci.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre délégué
en charge du logement.
La crise du logement est un sujet
désormais politique.
Le congrès HLM
qui vient de s'ouvrir
ce matin en témoigne.
Professionnel
du secteur de l'habitat
pendant plus de 20
ans avant d'être député,
je partage les inquiétudes
des acteurs
du logement, des élus locaux,
des entreprises
et des habitants
qui cherchent un logement.
La cote d'alerte
est aujourd'hui atteinte.
La filière
immobilière
est en train de s'arrêter.
Il lui faudra
beaucoup de temps
pour redémarrer.
Nous faisons face
à trois crises:
crise de la production
du logement neuf,
il ne se vend plus.
Déjà, certains acteurs
immobiliers préparent
des plans sociaux.
Conséquence
de cette même crise,
crise du marché locatif,
avec un calendrier d'interdictions
de mises en location de logements.
Ce n'est plus le cas
parce qu'en fait,
cette réforme a été
prévue en temps calme.
La transition
énergétique de l'habitat
est une nécessité,
mais ne rajoutons
pas de la crise à la crise.
Crise du parcours
résidentiel, enfin.
Notre politique
du logement a fait
le deuil
de la mobilité,
que ce soit dans le parc
HLM
ou dans le parc privé.
La fluidité du marché
de l'immobilier doit
être notre seul guide
dans cette période difficile.
C'est pourquoi le projet de loi
de finances doit absolument
amorcer la sortie de crise
par des mesures fortes,
urgentes et exceptionnelles.
Ce budget doit
être un plan de sauvetage,
de relance et d'espoir
pour les habitants.
Quelle est votre feuille de route?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Patrice Vergriete.
- Patrice Vergriete:
Monsieur le député Jolivet,
vous m'interpellez
sur la triple crise
que connaît aujourd'hui
le logement,
et le gouvernement partage
votre diagnostic.
Après 15 ans de forte hausse
des prix fonciers
et immobiliers,
la hausse des taux d'intérêt,
l'augmentation
du coût des matériaux
ont effectivement
largement déstabilisé
le modèle de production
du logement,
et ce au moment même
où l'urgence climatique
nous commande
une ambition forte
en matière de transition
écologique.
La réponse
du gouvernement doit
être sur les deux ambitions.
Nous ne pouvons pas d'un côté
répondre
à l'urgence environnementale
en sacrifiant d'urgence sociale,
ou l'inverse.
Il faut tenir les deux exigences.
La transition
écologique
n'est pas une option,
mais l'accès
à un logement
abordable et décent
non plus.
Pour ce faire, le gouvernement
a déjà enclenché
un certain nombre de mesures.
Christophe Béchu
l'évoquait tout à l'heure,
le maintien du taux
du livret A,
qui correspond à 1,4 milliard
en termes d'apports
aux bailleurs sociaux.
Mais il aurait pu ajouter
les 250 millions
de fonds propres
pour les bailleurs sociaux.
Il aurait pu ajouter les 700
millions d'apports
du gouvernement
pour accompagner
la rénovation énergétique.
Il aurait pu
ajouter le maintien
du prêt à taux zéro
sur l'ensemble
du territoire national
pour l'accession sociale.
Il aurait pu ajouter
le renforcement
du logement locatif intermédiaire,
élargi aujourd'hui
à 200.000 communes
supplémentaires.
Mais nous continuerons
à travailler
sur d'autres mesures.
Nous allons travailler
sur le crédit bancaire
avec Bruno Le Maire,
mais aussi
avec les bailleurs sociaux.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Loïc Prud'homme.
- Loïc Prud'homme: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre
Marc Fesneau,
alors que la Commission européenne
souhaiterait autoriser
le glyphosate
pour 10 ans,
vous avez déclaré
dans Ouest-France faire confiance
aux études qui indiquent
que le glyphosate
ne cause pas de cancer.
Est-ce les études de bailleurs
qui ignorent beaucoup
de données?
Beaucoup d'études ont conclu
au caractère cancérogène,
et perturbateur
endocrinien du glyphosate.
Tout le monde
connaît les dangers
du glyphosate.
En 2017, Emmanuel Macron
était aussi convaincu
et avait promis
d'interdire le glyphosate
dans les trois ans.
Son renoncement
a des conséquences
très concrètes.
On voit la multiplication
de clusters
de cancers pédiatriques.
Les cancers
se multiplient aussi
chez les agriculteurs.
Ne me dites pas qu'il n'est pas
possible d'interdire
le glyphosate faute d'alternative.
Les agriculteurs
bio s'en passent
très bien depuis des décennies.
Monsanto a quelque chose
à vendre,
mais vous, personne
ne peut croire
que vous allez brader la santé
des agriculteurs,
des Français
et des écosystèmes
pour les profits
d'une multinationale?
Pouvez-vous nous rassurer
et nous confirmer
que la France va voter
contre l'arrêt
de l'autorisation du glyphosate
le 13 octobre prochain?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu:
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs
les députés, monsieur
le député Loïc Prud'homme.
La Commission
européenne a mis
sur la table une proposition
de réhomologation
pour 10 ans du glyphosate.
La position de notre pays
est d'écouter
les scientifiques.
Nous avons en l'espèce
du mal à croire
et à comprendre
que la Commission européenne
n'écoute pas y compris ce que dit
l'autorité européenne
des aliments, qui dit
qu'il est préférable d'approfondir
les études, y compris
sur la biodiversité.
Depuis 2018,
la position de la France
est d'interdire
le glyphosate
dès lors qu'il y a
des alternatives
de substitution.
C'est ce qu'il s'est passé
pour la totalité
des usages non agricoles.
Dans le processus
européen,
si nous souhaitons
nous opposer
à la Commission européenne,
il faut réunir
une majorité des deux tiers.
La France
ne soutient pas la proposition
européenne de réhomologation
sans condition
du glyphosate.
Elle travaille à la construction
d'une majorité
qui évite les distorsions
de concurrence
avec des situations
nationales,
et qu'on se retrouve
dans des situations
où on n'écoute pas la science,
et enfin
qu'on ne retourne pas en arrière.
Je sais que vous aimez
que les choses soient binaires,
mais entre les deux,
derrière l'apparence
de la radicalité
et derrière la simplicité,
il y a une grande
part de démagogie
qui ne tient compte
ni de la nuance
ni de la science.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Naegelen.
- Christophe Naegelen: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre,
nos entreprises françaises
subissent une double peine.
Le prix de l'énergie
reste exorbitant.
Les concurrents
internationaux,
pour certains,
ont des conditions sociales
et fiscales bien
moins reluisantes:
les entreprises
textiles
en sont le parfait exemple.
Cette filière
compte
encore plus de 62.000
emplois en France
et plus de 33.000 dans les Vosges.
Après la récente liquidation
d'une entreprise
de 48 salariés,
à qui je pense en posant
cette question,
il est nécessaire
pour le gouvernement
de comprendre
la difficulté de cette filière.
Il ne reste plus qu'un seul
filateur français.
Il achète sa matière
première au prix
où la concurrence
internationale vend
sa matière filée.
Les filateurs
pakistanais vendent
leurs tissus 60% moins cher.
Vous comprendrez
que cet exemple
n'est pas unique, mais symbolique.
Il concerne aussi bien
d'autres industries,
et même l'agriculture.
Quand allons nous sortir
de l'accord européen
qui indexe l'électricité
sur le prix
du gaz?
A l'heure où nous parlons
de la réindustrialisation
française,
que comptez-vous faire
pour empêcher
nos savoir-faire historiques
de fermer ou de s'expatrier?
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci.
Monsieur le président
Christophe Naegelen,
le gouvernement
est particulièrement mobilisé
pour soutenir
l'industrie
dans notre pays.
Je suis convaincue
qu'il y a de la place
pour une industrie
compétitive en France.
Je sais l'importance
de ce secteur
de votre département
des Vosges
et votre engagement
pour le défendre.
Soutenir l'industrie,
c'est le sens
de la politique
menée depuis 2017,
avec la réforme
du marché du travail,
la baisse des impôts
de production
et le soutien
à l'innovation,
à travers le programme
France Relance
ou aujourd'hui, France 2030.
Je peux vous assurer
que le gouvernement
est mobilisé pour régler
ces difficultés.
Je vous invite à évoquer
cette situation
avec les ministres
de l'Industrie
et du Travail.
Les usines
aujourd'hui rouvrent,
nous avons besoin
de salariés qualifiés
et formés.
C'est aussi tout le sens
de notre politique
en faveur de l'apprentissage
de la réforme
des lycées professionnels.
Je sais que la hausse
des prix de l'énergie
a été difficile
pour beaucoup d'entreprises,
notamment dans le secteur
consommateur
comme le textile.
Nous avons pris
des mesures
comme le bouclier
tarifaire
pour les très petites
entreprises
et l'amortisseur électricité.
25 milliards d'euros
ont été déployés
pour aider les entreprises.
L'Etat a pris
en charge jusqu'à 40%
de la hausse
de leurs factures d'énergie.
Nous n'abordons pas l'hiver
de la même manière.
Les prix sont plus bas,
les stocks
de gaz sont remplis
à plus de 80%
et les équipes
d'EDF vont assurer
notre production nucléaire.
Je salue leur engagement
et leur professionnalisme.
Certaines entreprises
continuent
à avoir des difficultés,
notamment
celles qui ont signé
des contrats pluriannuels.
Elles seront
toujours protégées
par l'amortisseur électricité.
Le projet de loi de finances
prévoit 800 millions d'euros
pour continuer à les soutenir.
Nous réformons le marché
de l'électricité
au niveau européen
comme en France.
Notre objectif est d'offrir
des prix compétitifs
pour tous les consommateurs
français, afin
que chacun puisse
bénéficier
de nos investissements
dans le nucléaire.
Des discussions sont en cours
et devraient aboutir
au cours du mois d'octobre.
Ces discussions vont permettre
de concilier l'intérêt
des Français
et la préservation
des grands équilibres
financiers d'EDF,
acteur clé de la transition
énergétique.
Notre principe
est de ne laisser personne
sur le côté.
Nous n'en dévirons pas.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
Monsieur Christophe Naegelen?
- Christophe Naegelen: Merci.
Il est vrai
qu'en France,
nous avons une chance,
c'est notre parc nucléaire.
Nous devons impérativement
nous en servir
et le remettre
au centre du jeu,
afin que nos industries
puissent
en profiter.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Dino Cinieri.
- Dino Cinieri: Merci.
Madame la Première
ministre,
avec mes collègues du groupe
Les Républicains,
nous attirons
votre attention
sur la révision d'un texte
européen relatif
aux émissions industrielles.
A l'heure où la France
est engagée
sur ce texte,
nous souhaitons connaître
la position
qui sera défendue
par les ministres français.
Ce texte vise à faire entrer
les élevages bovins
dans le champ de la directive
aux émissions industrielles.
Cela présente un danger
pour nos élevages
et nos territoires.
Les éleveurs de bovins,
et notamment
les éleveurs laitiers
du département
de la Loire, sont déjà
soumis à l'application
de trois directives
concernant le traitement
de leurs rejets.
Les contraintes
administratives
sont lourdes.
Il faut protéger
les élevages
en les excluant
de cette directive.
Si elles étaient confirmées,
le surcoût
pour une exploitation
laitière d'une centaine
de vaches oscillerait
entre 20.000
et 27.000 euros.
C'est intenable
et inacceptable
pour nos agriculteurs.
Allez-vous écouter nos éleveurs?
Vos ministres
vont-ils respecter
le vote des eurodéputés
qui ont largement rejeté l'entrée
des élevages bovins
dans le champ
de la directive
en juillet dernier?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Laurence Boone.
- Laurence Boone: Merci.
Je veux vous rassurer,
monsieur le député.
La France connaît
évidemment les difficultés
des agriculteurs.
J'étais moi-même
en Haute-Savoie récemment
et j'ai pu voir
à quel point les élevages
étaient importants,
mais aussi
leurs demandes en matière
de réglementation européenne.
La France a agi
dès que cette directive
a été proposée
par la commission afin
de modifier les seuils
qui s'appliqueraient
aux bovins.
Nous ne souhaitons pas
que cela s'applique
aux exploitations
de moins de 350 bêtes.
Nous allons continuer
de nous battre
pour maintenir cette position.
Nous voulons
que pour nos agriculteurs,
nous trouvions
le bon équilibre
entre préserver
la qualité
de notre élevage et préserver
nos objectifs climatiques.
Il y a une chose
à laquelle
nous sommes attachés
depuis longtemps,
c'est d'avoir des clauses
miroirs
pour nous assurer
que le boeuf
qui entre sur le territoire
européen satisfait
aux mêmes exigences que le boeuf
européen lui-même.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
Monsieur Dino Cinieri?
- Dino Cinieri:
Je ne suis pas convaincu
par vos propos.
Nous serons vigilants
dans les semaines
qui viennent.
Avec les éleveurs,
nous n'attendons
pas de belles paroles
mais des actes.
Je solliciterai
une rencontre avec monsieur
le ministre de l'Agriculture.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Emmanuel Pellerin.
- Emmanuel Pellerin: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
Sylvie Retailleau.
J'y associe
notre collègue
Constance Le Grip.
Je souhaite attirer
votre attention
sur une préoccupation urgente,
l'antisémitisme persistant
au sein de l'enseignement
supérieur français.
Selon une enquête récente,
9 étudiants juifs
sur 10 déclarent
avoir été victimes d'au
moins un acte
antisémite au cours
de leurs études.
L'histoire de Jérémy
a été révélée
par Le Parisien.
Cet étudiant âgé de 23
ans a été confronté
à des chants nazis,
des slogans antisémites
et des agressions
verbales et physiques.
Ces actes antisémites
prennent la forme
de stéréotypes
ou de blagues parfois liées
à la Shoah.
Des slogans antisémites
ont été tagués
sur un mur de la faculté
de Paris VIII.
Ceci illustre
l'antisémitisme pratiqué
par certains groupuscules
d'extrême gauche
qui font des juifs de France
des ambassadeurs
de la politique
du gouvernement israélien.
L'enquête révèle aussi
que des préjugés
à l'encontre
des étudiants juifs
sont largement répandus.
Pour 24%, les juifs
seraient plus riches
que la moyenne.
Pour 18%,
ils détiendraient
plus de pouvoir dans les médias.
L'expression
"Dragon Céleste" issue
d'un manga est utilisée
comme métaphore antisémite
sur les réseaux sociaux.
Ceci souligne l'impérieuse
nécessité d'une réaction
politique.
Quelles mesures...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Sylvie Retailleau,
ministre de l'Enseignement
supérieur
et de la Recherche.
- Sylvie Retailleau:
Merci beaucoup,
madame la présidente.
Monsieur le député
Emmanuel Pellerin,
merci pour votre question,
qui me permet d'aborder
avec vous un sujet
grave et qui doit
tous nous mobiliser:
la lutte
contre l'antisémitisme.
C'est pour moi l'occasion
de rappeler l'engagement total
du gouvernement
pour enrayer ce fléau qui,
malheureusement,
agit aussi au niveau
des universités.
Je veux être claire.
L'antisémitisme n'a
sa place nulle part,
en particulier
dans l'enseignement supérieur.
Il est inconcevable
qu'un étudiant puisse
être inquiété pour ses convictions
religieuses, réelles
ou supposées.
Qu'il s'agisse
d'agressions physiques
ou parfois de faits
trop souvent minimisés,
comme des blagues
ou des allusions,
il n'y a que des violences
avérées
et inadmissibles.
Nous allons déployer
un plan de lutte
contre l'antisémitisme,
le racisme
et les discriminations.
Il va permettre
de repérer ces actes.
Il faut d'abord
accompagner les victimes,
ce qui permet
de libérer la parole.
Nous allons ensuite
apporter des réponses
de type disciplinaire
ou judiciaire.
Le président d'université
en a le pouvoir.
Vous avez parlé de tag.
Il est urgent de remédier
à cela également.
Nous allons déployer
des référents antisémitisme,
racisme
et discrimination
dans tous les établissements.
Nous essayons
de mieux identifier
ces agents
pour que les étudiants
les identifient
afin de mener
cette lutte.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, madame
la ministre.
La parole est à madame
Marietta Karamanli.
- Marietta Karamanli: Merci.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Education.
La Première ministre
a annoncé des mesures
en termes de lutte
contre le harcèlement
des élèves à l'école.
Ma question porte
sur l'éducation
et la prise de conscience,
d'autres maux
qui menacent nos enfants.
L'article 312-16 du code
de l'éducation dispose qu'une
information et
une éducation à la sexualité
soient dispensées
dans les établissements
et écoles
à raison d'au
moins trois séances annuelles.
Ce même code énonce
qu'une séance annuelle d'information
et de sensibilisation
sur l'enfance maltraitée,
notamment sur les violences
intrafamiliales
à caractère sexuel
soit inscrite à l'emploi
du temps de tous les élèves.
Le code indique
aussi qu'il faut
des formations
sur les conséquences
de la consommation
de drogues
au moins une fois par an.
Le seul bilan
quantitatif rendu public
sur l'éducation à la sexualité
montrait qu'en 2022,
moins de 20% des élèves
y avaient accès.
Les enseignants sont moins formés.
La présence
des personnels de santé
ou psychologues
est aussi moindre
au sein des établissements.
Quels moyens
pour la détection,
mais aussi pour la prise en charge
allez-vous engager
en faveur de la lutte
contre tous
ces fléaux?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Gabriel Attal.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci.
Vous l'avez souligné vous-même,
la Première ministre
a présenté un plan
interministériel
de lutte contre le harcèlement.
Il est important de le noter.
C'est la première
fois que cet enjeu
est porté à ce niveau.
Cela pousse tous
les ministères
à se mettre
à la hauteur du défi
et de l'enjeu que constitue
le harcèlement scolaire.
Sur ce sujet, il faut
des mesures claires.
Je crois que c'est ce que
nous avons présenté
dans tous les domaines,
qu'il s'agisse
de la prévention,
de la détection
ou de la réaction à ce phénomène.
Nous avons eu
l'occasion d'annoncer
des moyens pour renforcer
nos rectorats, afin
d'être capables de prendre
en charge mieux
ces situations.
Nous avons aussi
ouvert une réflexion
sur la médecine scolaire.
Nous avons besoin de médecins
et d'infirmiers scolaires.
Un certain nombre
de mesures ont été prises
ces dernières années,
notamment en matière
de rémunération.
On voit qu'on a un enjeu
d'attractivité
encore aujourd'hui
afin de pourvoir
les nombreux
postes ouverts
qui ne trouvent pas preneurs.
Il faut donc être inventifs
et imaginatifs
sur les réponses
à apporter à ces enjeux
qui sont essentiels.
Mon prédécesseur avait saisi
le conseil supérieur
des programmes
sur le dernier point
que vous avez évoqué.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
Madame Marietta Karamanli?
- Marietta Karamanli:
Des engagements,
nous en recevons beaucoup.
Des comptes rendus
précis, quantifiés,
très peu.
Je vous remercie
de ces éléments
que vous venez
d'apporter,
mais votre réponse
n'est pas complète.
Je voudrais
vous réinterroger afin
de savoir si ces mesures
jugées utiles
par la représentation
nationale
sont mises en oeuvre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Sébastien Jumel.
- Sébastien Jumel:
La saison de la coquille
Saint-Jacques vient d'ouvrir.
Le prix du carburant
pêche se rapproche
de 1 euro le litre.
Il était de 60
centimes il y a un an.
L'Etat va bientôt mettre
fin à la ristourne
de 20 centimes d'euro
le litre instauré
pour accompagner la pêche
après la flambée
des prix de l'énergie
liée à la guerre
en Ukraine.
La guerre n'est pas finie.
Le prix du combustible
ne faiblit pas.
L'aide va s'arrêter.
C'est une décision lourde
pour une filière
qui a essuyé
plusieurs tempêtes
qui ont fait mal aux trésoreries.
Je pense au Covid,
ainsi qu'au Brexit.
Certains armements
vont jouer leur vie.
Le prix du poisson n'évolue pas.
Le gasoil représente
plus de 35%
des charges de l'armement.
Avec la rentabilité
plombée, la fiche
de paye des marins
pêcheurs plombée.
Vous avez annoncé
quelques mesures alternatives
au niveau du carburant.
Elles ne nous ont pas
convaincus
et elles n'ont pas convaincu
les quais.
Ce sont des choses
qui existent déjà,
comme les 7% de bio gasoil.
Vu l'impact économique
du prix de l'énergie
sur la pêche,
la question urgente
est de savoir si vous allez
accompagner concrètement
nos armements de pêche.
J'étais il y a quelques jours
à Dieppe
où les marins-pêcheurs
attendent
des mesures.
Je pense notamment
à la proposition d'une taxe
flottante qui amortira
les vagues
de hausse en attendant
la décarbonation.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Hervé Berville.
- Hervé Berville: Merci.
Ce n'est pas l'Etat
qui met fin
à cette aide au carburant,
c'est cadre européen
dans lequel
nous sommes qui ne permet
pas à ce stade de le prolonger.
Comme vous le savez,
je suis comme vous,
je soutiens
les pêcheurs,
mais nous mettons
aussi des actes
derrière les paroles.
Depuis un an, la France
est le seul pays
qui a soutenu à cette hauteur
ses marins-pêcheurs.
Nous avons prolongé
par quatre fois l'aide
au carburant.
Nous avons prolongé
aussi et augmenté
le plafond,
qui est passé de 30.000
à 330.000 euros.
Je le dis clairement,
et je remercie
tous les députés
qui se sont impliqués
sur ce dossier depuis un an,
nous n'allons laisser
aucun marin-pêcheur
dans l'impasse.
Nous allons continuer
à mobiliser
les pays européens
afin de prolonger
cette aide carburant
au-delà du 15.
Il y a une hausse
du carburant qui pèse
sur la trésorerie
des entreprises,
c'est un fait.
Nous devons, à côté
de cela, travailler
sur des mécanismes de solidarité.
Il y a un certain
nombre de projets
sur la table.
Cette ristourne,
ce n'est pas nouveau.
C'est quelque chose
qui permettra
d'avoir à la pompe
une baisse de 13 centimes.
Nous devons dire
quelle est la trajectoire
de décarbonation,
de réduction
de la dépendance
aux énergies fossiles.
Les 452 millions d'euros
qui y seront dédiés,
ce n'est pas du vent.
Nous allons engager
les premiers financements.
Nous travaillons
au niveau européen
et au niveau des territoires
afin d'accompagner
tous les pêcheurs.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Vous n'avez plus de temps,
chers collègues.
La parole est à monsieur
Philippe Frei.
- Philippe Frei:
Il y a beaucoup
de punaises de lit
qui sont de retour
dans le quotidien
des Français,
avec une prolifération
qui doit
vous interpeller.
Véritable fléau,
les punaises de lit suscitent
une inquiétude
très forte au sein
de l'opinion publique,
tant il est difficile
de s'en débarrasser en raison
d'une résistance
aux insecticides et au prix
de l'intervention.
Véritable tabou,
les punaises de lit suscitent
la honte,
alors que les infestations
ne présentent aucun lien
avec un manque d'hygiène.
La ville
comme la campagne peuvent
être confrontées à ce fléau.
Si elles transmettent pas
de maladie,
elles peuvent être à l'origine
de conséquences dermatologiques
graves.
La punaise de lit
est aussi un désastre
pour la santé
mentale des gens
qui en sont victimes.
Notre majorité est mobilisée.
Dès 2020, un numéro
d'appel a été mis
en place qui a permis
de rassurer
et d'orienter les Français.
Un plan interministériel
a été mis
en place pour accentuer
la lutte
contre ce fléau.
Dans la continuité
des mesures déjà initiées,
quelles réponses
le gouvernement peut continuer
à apporter
sur le plan sanitaire
et économique?
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Aurélien Rousseau.
- Aurélien Rousseau:
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs
les députés, monsieur
le député.
Comme la Première
ministre l'a dit
tout à l'heure
et comme votre question
le sous-tendait,
être infecté
par les punaises de lit
est un calvaire quotidien.
Les Français,
de façon
de plus en plus nombreuses,
le vivent.
C'est une réalité
que l'on croise
dans de nombreux pays.
C'est une des conséquences
du réchauffement climatique.
Notre responsabilité
est de cinq ordres.
La première est de mettre
à disposition
de nos concitoyens
une information fiable,
claire
et précise,
qui ne repose pas
uniquement
sur le recours
aux pesticides,
alors même que cela crée
de la résistance
chez ces insectes.
Notre deuxième
responsabilité,
c'est de poursuivre
la recherche
sur ces nuisibles
et nous sommes largement mobilisés
afin de savoir
quels traitements
sont les plus à même d'y répondre.
Notre troisième
responsabilité,
il y aura dans quelques heures
une réunion
avec tous les acteurs,
bailleurs sociaux,
entreprises, représentants
des locataires
et propriétaires,
afin d'engager ensemble
le combat.
Le dernier point,
c'est celui qui consiste
à ce que nos concitoyens
ne tombent
pas dans le piège
de certains qui,
voulant profiter
de leur détresse,
voudraient faire
des profits
sur leur dos.
On trouvera sur le site
du gouvernement
480 entreprises référencées.
Nous allons produire
une action résolue
pour qu'il n'y
ait pas de voyous
qui profitent
de la détresse
de nos concitoyens.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Alexandra Martin.
- Alexandra Martin: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre
de l'Education nationale,
depuis votre nomination,
vous avez fait preuve d'une
volonté certaine de combattre
le fléau sociétal qu'est
le harcèlement scolaire.
Il est vrai
que la France accuse
un très grand retard
dans ce domaine,
contrairement à de nombreux
pays européens.
Vos annonces devront
être déclinées rapidement
et en actions concrètes,
en espérant
qu'il ne s'agisse pas
encore d'effets
de communication.
Nous avons créé au sein
des Républicains
un groupe d'études consacré
au harcèlement scolaire.
Nous serons donc
très vigilants
sur la mise en oeuvre
des propositions
que vous avez formulées.
Nous avons également
demandé la mise
en place d'une commission
d'enquête parlementaire.
La lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire,
pour être efficace,
doit être appréhendée
dans toutes ses dimensions,
et aussi
dans le temps long.
Nous connaissons
votre intérêt, inspiré
par la méthode danoise,
pour la mise
en place de cours d'empathie.
Je veux prendre ici
un autre modèle,
celui de la Suède.
Là-bas,
ce ne sont pas que des cours
d'empathie qui permettent
de résoudre
les problèmes, mais la façon
de concevoir l'éducation
des enfants de façon positive
et bienveillante.
Si nous sommes programmés
pour faire preuve d'empathie,
celle-ci doit pouvoir
se développer
et s'entretenir tout au long
du parcours éducatif
et aussi au sein de la famille.
Pour cela,
il est nécessaire également
de soutenir et d'accompagner
les établissements
qui sont souvent
sans ressources
et doivent pallier la pénurie
de psychologues,
d'infirmières, de surveillants.
Nous devons aussi
leur permettre d'élaborer
un plan de lutte adapté
aux spécificités
des établissements.
N'est-ce pas un véritable
changement
de paradigme
que nous appelons
de nos voeux au sein
des Républicains
qu'il faut entreprendre?
Un changement
systémique, culturel,
qui serait aussi
propice à faire baisser
le phénomène
croissant de violence
chez les jeunes,
dans la rue,
sur les réseaux
sociaux et à apprendre
aux adultes de demain le civisme.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Gabriel Attal.
- Gabriel Attal:
Madame la députée
Alexandra Martin,
je vous remercie.
Je crois au dialogue
et à la capacité
que l'on doit avoir à avancer
collectivement
et largement.
S'il est un sujet
sur lequel on peut avancer
en dépassant
les clivages politiques,
c'est la lutte
contre le harcèlement.
Pour construire le plan
que la Première ministre
a présenté, j'ai réuni
des représentants
de chaque groupe
parlementaire,
vous en faisiez
partie pour LR,
je vous en remercie.
Je remercie tous
les membres
de chaque groupe parlementaire.
Je remercie
la représentation nationale
de s'emparer collectivement
de ce sujet.
La réalité,
c'est que nous avons besoin
d'une mobilisation collective
qui dépasse l'enceinte
de cet hémicycle.
C'est un sursaut
collectif de la société
dont nous avons besoin.
J'ai parlé d'un électrochoc.
L'électrochoc a démarré,
avec la libération
de la parole,
une multiplication
par 3 des signalements
de harcèlements
sur le mois de septembre
2023 par rapport
à septembre 2022.
Notre responsabilité
à nous,
c'est d'être capables
d'y répondre.
Vous avez raison
d'être vigilante
sur la déclinaison
du plan
que nous avons annoncé.
Les jeunes
parlent
parce qu'ils ont
un d'espoir
qu'on les entende
et qu'on agisse,
et on va bien agir.
C'est un véritable
changement de paradigme
sur la question
de la prévention,
avec cette capacité
à développer
dès les premières classes
cette éducation bienveillante
d'empathie.
Il faut revenir
à Jean-Jacques Rousseau
qui disait:
"Il y a l'instruction
de l'esprit
et l'instruction du coeur."
C'est la responsabilité
de l'école
que d'apporter ça à nos élèves.
Le changement de paradigme,
c'est aussi
de faire en sorte
que la peur change
de camp.
Ce plan nous permet
de dire aux harceleurs
qui empoisonnent
la vie de centaines
de millions d'élèves
que nous ne laisserons rien passer
et que nous serons
intraitables en matière
de sanctions.
Le changement de paradigme
est aussi là,
et c'est important
de le réaffirmer
tous ensemble.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Nicolas Thierry.
- Nicolas Thierry: Merci.
Madame la Première
ministre,
après le temps des discours
sur la planification écologique
vient le temps des actes.
En la matière,
votre gouvernement
a l'opportunité de prendre
une initiative historique
pour le vivant.
Mon collègue
Loïc Prud'homme
vous a questionnée.
Vous allez porter
la voix de la France
sur le renouvellement
de l'autorisation
du glyphosate
dans l'Union Européenne.
En 2017,
lors du précédent vote
des Etats-membres,
la France avait voté
contre la réautorisation
du glyphosate.
Une position louable
qui n'a pas suffi
à emporter la décision
car l'Allemagne
avait voté pour.
Depuis, Emmanuel Macron
a échoué à interdire
le glyphosate
sur le territoire français.
En 2022, il avait déclaré
que c'était l'erreur
qu'il avait commise
en début de quinquennat
et qu'il fallait
agir sur ce sujet
au niveau européen.
Les conditions sont réunies
pour concrétiser cet engagement
du président au niveau européen.
Sur le plan politique,
l'Allemagne
a changé de cap
et annonce
qu'elle ne votera pas
la réautorisation.
Le vote de la France va donc
être déterminant.
Son vote va conditionner
l'arrêt autorisation
du glyphosate.
Sur le plan sanitaire,
le doute n'a
plus lieu d'être.
Le glyphosate est classé
cancérogène probable
depuis huit ans par l'OMS.
La France reconnaît
que les effets
du glyphosate sont incontestables.
La seule position
qui vaille
est celle du refus
de toute réautorisation
du glyphosate.
Une majorité se dessine
sur cette position.
La France peut s'y rallier.
La position exprimée
par Christophe Béchu manque
de clarté.
La question est simple:
la position
de la France sera-t-elle
la même qu'en 2017,
un vote
contre tout renouvellement
de l'autorisation
de mise sur le marché
du glyphosate?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Sarah El Haïry.
- Sarah El Haïry:
Monsieur le député Thierry,
aujourd'hui, la position
de la commission
ne correspond pas,
ne convient pas
à la position française.
La reconduction
comme elle est proposée,
c'est la facilité.
La politique,
ce n'est pas la facilité.
Qu'est-ce que nous souhaitons?
Nous souhaitons
d'ores et déjà,
et ce que nous avons fait
en France, baisser
la consommation de glyphosate.
Dans les 15
dernières années,
30% de baisse
sur le glyphosate,
c'est la plus grande
baisse
depuis les 15 dernières années.
C'est bien cette position
que nous allons défendre
au sein de l'Union Européenne.
Nous avons interdit
le glyphosate
dans tous les usages
non agricoles.
C'est nous qui l'avons
fait,
dans les parcs.
Et aujourd'hui,
c'est quoi, la réalité?
C'est plus de glyphosate
en France
dans nos parcs
et dans nos jardins,
pas de glyphosate
non agricole,
une baisse de l'utilisation
du glyphosate
dans nos exploitations.
Nous voulons accompagner
les agriculteurs autant
que possible
pour ne pas rompre
une compétitivité
nécessaire, même
au sein de l'Union Européenne.
Aujourd'hui,
la Commission nous renvoie
vers un risque
de distorsion
entre les agriculteurs
parce qu'elle appelle
à la protection
spécifique Etat
par Etat.
La France sera
au rendez-vous,
puisque c'est la position
française
qui est la plus ambitieuse,
baisser
la consommation
du glyphosate,
et c'est ce que
nous continuerons
à faire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur le député?
- Nicolas Thierry: Merci.
Je constate simplement
qu'en 2017,
la position de la France
était extrêmement claire.
Aujourd'hui,
vous tergiversez,
et il faut le dire,
vous faites un revirement
sur un sujet fondamental
de la transition écologique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Madame la ministre?
- Sarah El Haïry:
Monsieur le député,
il n'y a aucun revirement.
La réalité et la position
sont claires.
Un accompagnement
de nos agriculteurs
pour tenir notre compétitivité
et s'appuyer
sur la science.
Les préconisations
pour la santé
et sur la biodiversité sont là.
A chaque fois
qu'il a une alternative,
on interdit.
A chaque fois
que c'est nécessaire,
on investit.
On s'appuie
sur les rapports de l'Anses
et d'autres.
Une seule et unique
boussole: l'ambition.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Didier Lemaire.
- Didier Lemaire: Merci.
J'associe l'ensemble
de mes collègues Horizons
à ma question
destinée à monsieur
le ministre de l'Economie.
Il y a à peine trois mois,
le Parlement adoptait
à la quasi-unanimité
une loi concernant
le risque d'incendie,
permettant d'une part
l'exonération des taxes
sur les carburants,
mais également la suppression
du malus écologique
pour l'ensemble des véhicules
des SDIS.
Certaines dispositions
de l'article 12
du PLF 2024 inquiètent
nos soldats
du feu, et bon nombre
de nos collègues parlementaires,
à juste titre.
Par la voix
du ministre Cazenave,
le gouvernement
a annoncé sa volonté
de faire conserver
les services
de la sécurité civile
certaines dispositions
qui leur donnent les moyens
supplémentaires.
Nous travaillons
actuellement
dans le cadre de la mission
d'information
sur la capacité d'anticipation
et l'adaptation
de notre modèle
de protection
et de sécurité civile.
Depuis quelques années,
les crises
se succèdent dans notre pays.
Or, notre modèle
de sécurité civile repose
sur un ensemble
de professionnels
et de volontaires.
Il est depuis plusieurs années
en tension perpétuelle,
il s'essouffle.
Les bénévoles font
un travail remarquable
de maillage social.
J'aimerais savoir s'il
dans le PLF 2024,
des mesures pour soutenir
et stabiliser
notre modèle de protection
et de sécurité civile
sont envisageables,
et le cas échéant, lesquelles.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Merci.
Monsieur le député
Didier Lemaire,
il y a 250.000
sapeurs-pompiers
dans ce pays
avec des statuts divers.
Il y a quelques semaines,
la représentation nationale
a joint le geste
à la parole en votant
à l'unanimité une proposition
de loi permettant
de les soutenir.
Je veux saluer en cet
instant les députés
qui ont été les rapporteurs
de ce texte
et qui ont travaillé
à faire en sorte
qu'il puisse être adopté
à l'unanimité.
Il n'y aura pas,
dans le projet de loi
de finances,
et je le dis en mon nom
et au nom
de la Première ministre
qui s'est exprimée
il y a quelques jours
de la manière
la plus claire qui soit,
je le dis au nom
du ministre de l'Economie
et des Finances
qui s'est exprimé aussi
et je le dis avec le ministre
de l'Intérieur,
puisque nous partageons,
avec Dominique Fort,
le suivi des services
d'incendie
et de secours, il n'y
aura pas de remise
en cause des avantages
concernant
les pompiers
dans le projet de loi
de finances.
Ni sur la remise
en cause
de ce qu'ils payent
en matière de GNR,
ni en mettant
en place un malus
sur les véhicules
de sécurité civile
qui serait absurde.
Il faut de la cohérence.
C'est évidemment
ce que nous allons faire,
en corrigeant cette coquille.
Je le dis de façon très claire.
Vous posez la question
de savoir comment
on fait pour conforter
le modèle
du volontariat dans notre pays.
Ce n'est pas aux députés
que je m'adresse
mais aux sapeurs-pompiers
professionnels
et ce ne sont pas que des textes.
C'est un suivi
et un accompagnement
avec les présidents
de département.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Pierrick Berteloot.
- Pierrick Berteloot:
Ma question s'adresse
à la ministre déléguée
chargée des petites
et moyennes entreprises,
du commerce, de l'artisanat
et du tourisme.
Les chambres des métiers
et de l'artisanat
sont financées
par une taxe payée
par tous les artisans.
Or, votre gouvernement
a décidé
de ne plus reverser
la totalité
de cette taxe aux CMA.
Les CMA sont financées
par les artisans
et les petites
entreprises qui payent
pour le fonctionnement
de cette structure publique.
En prenant cette décision
de détourner taxe,
l'Etat enlève 60
millions d'euros
sur un mandat de cinq ans.
Cette décision
de détourner cette taxe
a des conséquences très concrètes.
Dans ma région
des Hauts-de-France,
ce sont trois centres
de formation
dans la ruralité qui vont fermer.
Cela découle de la taxe,
mais également
de votre décret du mois
dernier prenant
une nouvelle prise
en charge du coût
de contrat d'apprentissage.
Pour certaines
formations, cela amorce
une baisse de 10%.
Au moment
où l'on a le plus besoin
de formation, où le gouvernement
prétend vouloir prendre soin
des artisans et de protéger
leurs activités,
il assène
un double couperet
pour ces chambres
qui forment nos jeunes.
C'est non seulement
profondément cynique
mais cela aura
des conséquences immédiates
et désastreuses.
C'est affaiblir
encore davantage
les artisans
qui ont encore
plus de mal à recruter
et à pérenniser
leur entreprise,
puisqu'il y aura
moins de formations
dispensées
par les CMA à cause
de votre décision.
Aussi je vous demande,
madame la ministre,
vous qui êtes l'autorité
de tutelle,
qu'est-ce que vous comptez
faire
pour maintenir
ces centres de formations
qui vont fermer à cause
de votre mesure?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Olivia Grégoire.
- Olivia Grégoire:
Monsieur le député Berteloot,
nous sommes d'accord sur un point,
incontestablement:
les chambres des métiers
sont un pilier indispensable
de notre vie économique
sur l'ensemble
des territoires
et un partenaire
de confiance pour tous.
C'est pourquoi
j'en profite
pour vous dire
qu'ils ont été
tout au long de l'année
à nos côtés,
aux côtés des artisans
qui souffraient
des prix de l'énergie.
Ils ont accompagné
des milliers d'entreprises.
Pour autant,
la situation du pays
nous conduit à faire
des choix difficiles.
Nous avons aujourd'hui
une situation
en matière
de finances publiques
qui doit tous nous mobiliser.
C'est pourquoi
nous avons demandé
un effort aux CMA.
Tout le monde doit participer.
Je les reçois
très régulièrement,
et je sais que c'est difficile
de faire autant
avec un peu moins,
mais je sais aussi
leur capacité et leur volonté
de s'adapter.
Je veux
revenir
sur ce que vous avez dit
concernant
les niveaux de prise en charge
des coûts contrats.
C'est annoncé
depuis juin 2022,
donc personne ne découvre rien.
Je veux aussi être claire:
cette baisse
des coûts contrats
ne fera pas baisser
les niveaux de prise en charge.
On a déjà accompagné une première
baisse l'an passé.
Il était prévu
qu'on continue
cette baisse.
Ca n'a en rien mis à mal
le nombre d'appétits.
Il y a une hausse
de 12% par rapport
à l'an dernier, malgré la coupe.
Je voudrais rappeler,
malgré l'effort demandé
que je ne nie pas,
que si un gouvernement
qui a mis des dizaines
de milliards d'euros,
s'il y a eu 15 milliards
d'euros investis
dans un plan
pour les compétences,
c'est ce gouvernement
qui l'a fait.
- Pierrick Berteloot:
Je constate
que le gouvernement
n'est pas du côté
des CMA.
Il est là pour détourner
les taxes
en sacrifiant
la formation et l'emploi.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Luc Geismar.
- Luc Geismar:
Ma question s'adresse
à madame la ministre
chargée des PME,
du commerce
et de l'artisanat
et du tourisme.
Lors de la conférence
nationale du handicap
en avril dernier,
le président
de la République a fait
d'importantes annonces concernant
l'accessibilité,
reconnaissant le chemin
que notre pays
a encore à parcourir
pour les personnes
handicapées
comme pour l'ensemble
de la société.
Dans la continuité
de l'action résolue
de ma collègue
Geneviève Darrieussecq
en faveur des personnes
en situation
de handicap,
un investissement de l'Etat
de 1,5 million a été
annoncé pour booster
la mise en accessibilité
des lieux publics
et des espaces numériques.
Les espaces
recevant du public
comme les commerces
de proximité,
les restaurants,
les bars,
dans nos villes
et nos campagnes,
sont les piliers
du bien vivre ensemble.
Leur mise
en accessibilité
n'est pas seulement
une obligation légale,
c'est surtout une nécessité
sociale.
C'est pourquoi il a été
décidé un fonds
de 300 millions
d'euros pour l'aide
et la mise en accessibilité
de ces établissements recevant
du public.
Je salue l'effort
substantiel
de notre pays en faveur
d'un meilleur accueil
de tous nos concitoyens.
Mais comme vous le savez,
mes chers collègues,
l'attente est longue
pour les publics intéressés.
Aussi, le temps presse.
Pouvez-vous nous dire
comment ce plan
va être décliné?
Avec les Jeux Olympiques
et Paralympiques,
le monde entier
aura les yeux rivés
sur notre pays.
Une phase
importante s'ouvre
devant nous, celle
de la mise en oeuvre
sur le terrain de ce plan.
Pour réussir
ce dernier kilomètre,
je sais la mobilisation
de vos services
et de l'ensemble
de nos commerçants
et établissements
accueillant du public,
afin de recevoir
dignement l'ensemble
de la population
dans les meilleures conditions.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Olivia Grégoire.
- Olivia Grégoire:
Monsieur le député Geismar,
merci de votre question.
Je vais répondre
aussi en mentionnant
les travaux de la ministre
Geneviève Darrieussecq
et en vous confirmant qu'avec
la ministre Fadila Khattabi,
sous l'autorité
de la Première ministre,
c'est un chantier,
c'est un impératif,
et nous nous y mettons
tous
et toutes très vite.
Vous vous souvenez
sûrement
de cette phrase
qui me mettait
très en colère,
donc je vais la partager
avec vous.
J'ai poussé pendant 25 ans
un fauteuil roulant.
On disait beaucoup
qu'il fallait changer
le regard.
Je le dis, et je sais
que le ministre
de la Santé me regarde.
Je crois que ce n'est
plus le regard
qu'il faut
qu'on change,
c'est leur vie
qu'il faut qu'on change.
Quand on a 6%
de personnes handicapées
dans ce pays,
c'est leur vie qu'il faut
qu'on change.
Et ça coûte rien.
Ca coûte
quelques milliers d'euros
de mettre une rampe
d'accessibilité.
Nous avons,
dans ce pays, et je sais
qu'on sera tous
d'accord sur tous
ces bancs, 500.000
établissements
qui reçoivent du public,
des commerces,
des cafés, des restaurants.
Nous avons une immense
majorité
qui n'est pas accessible.
Ca n'est pas acceptable.
La ministre des Sports
avec qui je travaille,
nous partageons ce point.
Le gouvernement met 300
millions d'euros
pour les années
qui viennent
pour toutes les villes et tous
les commerçants,
les hôteliers
et les restaurateurs
qui vont accueillir
des épreuves
lors des Jeux Olympiques.
Il y a 70 collectivités
concernées.
A partir du 2
novembre prochain,
sur le site de l'agence
des services
et des paiements,
et comptez
sur nous pour le communiquer
largement,
on travaille
avec les organisations
professionnelles,
tous vos commerces,
tous vos hôtels et tous
vos restaurants
vont pouvoir
bénéficier d'une prise
en charge de 50%
de leurs travaux
par l'Etat dans une limite
de 20.000 euros.
Je vous garantis
que ça permet de mettre
en accessibilité
des dizaines de milliers
de commerces, d'hôtels,
de restaurants.
Ces Jeux Olympiques
nous honorent,
mais ils nous obligent.
On y va comment?
Justement, en les rendant
accessibles.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, madame
la ministre.
Vous n'avez
plus de temps de parole.
Madame la ministre,
je vous remercie
de regagner votre place.
Madame la ministre!
Madame la ministre,
s'il vous plaît.
La parole est à Martine Etienne.
- Martine Etienne: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre
de la Santé,
le 15 septembre,
vous lanciez une grande campagne
de prévention
contre la bronchiolite.
15 jours plus tard,
c'est déjà la pénurie.
Faute de doses
de Beyfortus, le produit
qui permet
de protéger les bébés
de la bronchiolite,
vous êtes obligés
de stopper la livraison
en pharmacies
et de ne prioriser
que les maternités.
Encore une fois,
vous n'avez rien anticipé.
Alors qu'il y a eu
plus de 720.000 naissances
en 2022, vous n'avez commandé
que 200.000 doses.
Vous souhaitiez créer
un effet d'annonce
en prétendant
anticiper l'épidémie,
mais voilà aujourd'hui,
les doses manquent
et les parents s'alertent.
Vous n'apprenez rien
de vos erreurs.
La bronchiolite,
c'est quasiment 100.000 passages
aux urgences l'année
dernière, des dizaines
de milliers
d'hospitalisations
et des hôpitaux saturés
qui ont dû gérer
cette épidémie,
la grippe et le Covid
en même temps.
Malgré ça, vous continuez
de fonctionner
en flux tendu,
de commander
trop peu de doses,
de rogner
sur les stocks
et de désarmer le pays face
aux épidémies.
Il y a urgence.
En 2021, sur l'ensemble
du territoire, 2700 enfants
sont morts avant leur premier
anniversaire.
Les professionnels
de santé vous alertent
sur la dégradation
des soins
et sur la mortalité infantile.
Mais comme à votre habitude,
vous n'écoutez rien.
La recherche
et la santé
sont tellement
sous-financées
que la France est dépendante
d'une seule usine
aux Etats-Unis pour se fournir
en médicaments
contre la bronchiolite
et soigner
ses bébés.
Sous Emmanuel Macron,
les pénuries
de médicaments
ont été multipliées
par 7.
Parce que la santé
n'est pas un marché,
il est urgent de créer
un pôle public
du médicament en France
et de redonner
les moyens humains
et financiers
aux maternités et à la pédiatrie.
Alors, monsieur le ministre,
comment allez-vous faire
pour protéger la santé
de nos bébés?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à Aurélien Rousseau.
- Aurélien Rousseau:
Madame la députée,
quatre pays au monde
ont commandé
du Beyfortus.
La France, l'Espagne,
les Etats-Unis
et l'Allemagne.
En mars dernier,
un laboratoire
est venu voir mon prédécesseur
François Braun
et lui a proposé
un médicament qui n'avait
fait l'objet d'aucune
autorisation.
François Braun
a eu le courage
et il a pris le risque
de commander
des doses de ce médicament
qui n'avait
aucune autorisation.
Aujourd'hui,
si ce médicament
n'avait pas obtenu
les autorisations,
qu'est-ce que vous diriez
sur le fait
qu'on détruise des doses?
Les sociétés
savantes à l'époque
ont dit qu'il y aurait
sans doute 10% d'adhésion,
comme c'est un nouveau produit.
Le ministre de la Santé
a commandé 200.000 doses.
Et oui,
à la différence de vous,
je trouve
que c'est une formidable
nouvelle que,
dans les maternités,
on ait un taux
d'adhésion entre 60
et 80%.
C'est du jamais vu
en matière de vaccination
ou d'immunisation.
A partir de là,
ma responsabilité
et je l'assume,
c'est de protéger
les nourrissons les plus à risque.
Qui sont ceux qui ont été
les nourrissons hospitalisés
et plus à risque?
C'était
ceux qui avaient quelques jours
ou quelques semaines.
Oui, nous privilégions
les doses
de 50 mg de Beyfortus
dans les maternités.
En attendant, plutôt
que de nous faire
à nouveau la complainte
du drame,
nous travaillons au progrès.
La Première ministre,
le président
de la République,
moi-même,
nous nous battons
tous les jours
pour obtenir
plus de doses
et pour que la France
soit le pays
qui aura la plus grande
couverture
au Beyfortus dans le monde.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Pour la dernière
question, je donne
la parole à monsieur Paul Molac.
- Paul Molac: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre
de la Santé.
Carhaix, Redon,
Pontivy, Guingamp:
le point commun
de tous ces hôpitaux,
c'est la fermeture
de leurs services d'urgence
la nuit, voire le week-end.
Les élus de Carhaix
ont manifesté
ce week-end.
Je comprends l'émoi
et la colère
que suscitent ces manquements.
Selon le syndicat de France,
163 services d'urgence
ont fermé
au moins ponctuellement cet été.
C'est catastrophique.
Nous assistons
à un manque criant
de personnel médical,
en particulier
de médecins.
Cela conduit
à mettre en danger
nos populations.
Quelles mesures
envisagez-vous de prendre
pour que cette situation
ne se renouvelle pas?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Aurélien Rousseau.
- Aurélien Rousseau:
Monsieur le député,
oui, la situation
des urgences
et des services
d'urgences en particulier
est dégradée.
Oui, elle l'a été cet été.
Elle l'est
encore à la rentrée,
notamment en Bretagne.
Vous avez raison
de le souligner,
il n'y a là-dessus
aucune espèce
de déni.
Nous avons connu cet été,
sur les 680 services d'urgence
que notre pays compte,
cinq fermetures complètes.
Et en effet, on peut
discuter des chiffres,
il y a eu des fermetures
partielles
de services d'urgence,
ce qui a obligé
nos concitoyens
à passer par le 15,
qui les a orientés
vers le service
le plus proche
et ce qu'on appelle
la régulation.
Ce n'est pas une situation
satisfaisante.
La plupart
du temps,
et pour ne pas dire
tout le temps,
la raison qui a conduit
à ce système dégradé,
c'est le manque de personnel.
Nous avons donc pris
des décisions fortes
que la Première
ministre a annoncées
à Rouen, notamment
l'augmentation
de 25% sur le travail de nuit.
C'est un des points essentiels
de l'attractivité.
Pour reconnaître
le travail des assistants
de régulation médicale,
nous avons annoncé
la semaine dernière
une augmentation
de leurs indemnités
et de leurs grilles
de carrière.
Nous continuons
à investir pour la santé,
mais vous avez raison,
il y a des endroits
où nous ne tiendrons pas.
Nous devons avoir un système
dans lequel
il y a, notamment
pour les élus
mais aussi
pour les citoyens,
de la prévisibilité.
Il faut être associé
aux décisions
et avoir de l'anticipation.
Sur le territoire
de la Bretagne,
y compris sur celui
de Carhaix,
nous avons des propositions
et des projets.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur Paul Molac?
- Paul Molac:
Il y a une mesure
qui manque.
En 2012, j'avais
interrogé la ministre
de l'époque
sur les déserts médicaux.
On m'avait répondu:
"Ne vous inquiétez pas,
tout est sous contrôle.
Il y a assez de personnel
en formation.
Tout cela va se régler."
En 2014, j'ai dit:
"Les déserts médicaux,
ça continue.
Vous devez faire
un effort particulier
sur le numerus clausus."
En 2021, le numerus
clausus est devenu
le numerus apertus.
On l'avait augmenté de 20%.
C'est bien,
mais c'est insuffisant.
Il faut vraiment faire
un effort suffisant.
Je pense qu'il faudrait
augmenter
le nombre de médecins
en formation
de 50%.
Vu la démographie
médicale,
le plus dur,
c'est ce qui nous attend
dans les 10 et 20 ans à venir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La séance des questions
au gouvernement
est terminée.
La séance est suspendue.